[Music]
paul is in cincinnati hey paul welcome
to the ramsey show
hey dave and george how are you guys
doing great how can we help
um i just have a question for you i'm
hoping you can speak out of your
experience from when you and sharon hit
bottom
i'm wondering
how do i make it up to my wife for my
financial mistakes and wasteful spending
from before we started the baby steps
ah well obviously you stop
the activity yes sir right um and the
more time the more time that elapses
from the last time you were stupid the
the less she's gonna look at it
okay like in my case uh you know 30
years ago
uh
more than 30 years ago my goodness
gracious now uh 34 years ago we filed
bankruptcy
okay and we lost everything now so the
stuff that i did in that
is still inside of our marriage it's
still inside of our our psyche it's
still in our spirits
but it doesn't affect her
she's not nearly as afraid
today
of me doing that same stupid thing as
she was one month after i did it
does that make sense right so time
eighty percent is behavior change
concern yeah time is a great healer is
what i'm saying
uh as long as you don't keep doing it
right so uh but we used to you know we
used to say the joke and it wasn't
really a joke that uh we not only had an
emergency fund we had an emergency fund
for the emergency fund
because sharon was not going to be
without money ever again with little
kids because she was without money with
little kids
and uh you know she was terrified
literally it was not just afraid she was
terrified that we were going to be
homeless our our water got cut off our
electricity got cut off um
you know she was tariff and we had a
brand new baby named rachel and a
toddler named denise and so yeah it
didn't she didn't she didn't forget that
in a week
right
how did you earn back her trust not
doing it again for a long period of time
not doing it again right okay
we've uh we're in baby step two right
now and we're throwing like 4 500 per
month at our debt
on top of our regular payments and
i just you know we just started but
today i had to come to my life again
because i remembered another mistake
that i made that just hit the uh credit
card bill yes we've cut up the credit
card but i didn't see it till now
and uh
that wasn't a reasonable mistake it was
the it was the discovery of an old
mistake
you didn't hide it from her you didn't
hide it from her
and you didn't you didn't run the debt
up last week right
no okay no sure you just didn't see the
bill until you found it the other day
and you bring it to yourself
that shouldn't count against you
okay another thing is this we don't we
quit making decisions by ourselves
sharon and i did right we make decisions
together
and so we don't spend money
or make big financial decisions
without both of us being in agreement on
that
now the definition of big as our life
has gotten big
is different
okay but uh i mean if she goes and buys
something now
that you know with our current income
it's a different version of big right
but uh but but we don't but we're not
going to do something that's going to
interfere in in the in the lot in our
lives or
have a weight that we don't discuss it
and do it together and you guys you you
wouldn't have been doing that since you
started your relationship oh yeah i mean
i met her here at ramsey so it was easy
to be on the same page but that level of
open and honest communication that's
great marriage advice and it's great
money advice and the more honest you are
and the less things she's discovering uh
the better it's going to be for the long
term and like dave said as time goes on
there's going to be more trust that is
built there which means there's going to
be less of the the guilt and shame that
you're feeling right now which it sounds
like he's he's beating himself up over
these mistakes and i wanted to look to
the future the more she sees him
sacrificing wanting to get out of debt
communicating i think this will
dissipate but yeah
and back to the working together thing
that you were talking about that's
really
that's another element of it okay
because in our case i made all the
decisions i just did everything
and sharon was an innocent
she just it all happened to her okay
and so now we do a budget
and she
is if something screws up it's half her
fault because she had a vote she knew we
were doing it if something goes bad she
does not get it i told you so anymore
because it's we did it together they're
shared and so she has a sense of
it gives her a level of trust because
she is involved in the decision making
she's speaking into the budget okay
rather than it happening to her
and that increased her trust as well so
time heals all not repeating the
mistakes obviously full disclosure
full authenticity uh lots of
communication and she now has a vote
and so then she doesn't get to
gripe if something goes wrong
you know because you you we made this
decision together this is a dumb idea i
know we did it together we're dumb
together you know and we've done some
stuff since we went bankrupt then we
looked back on him and we go god that
was stupid but at least we were together
stupid you know it wasn't like i did it
and then she can point her finger
because she's a genius and i'm an idiot
you know we can't do that anymore i'm
like hey we were fellow idiots in that
one there were fellow geniuses in the
other one you know and that that's the
wins you share the loss yeah but
that is the beauty of the budget we
don't talk about that enough is because
a lot of spouses like to stand in the
sidelines and throw grenades over on the
one working on the budget and trying to
get the money done well if you just got
that over there or straightened out
there stand over there on the side and
look over the fence and yell about it
instead of getting back in the middle of
it and actually fixing the line
quarterback exactly exactly it does away
with the i told you so or the grenade
throwing from the neighbor's yard or
whatever you want to call it uh you both
are making the decision these are two
grown-ups one of you doesn't get to
whine ago and my husband won't let me my
wife won't let me
it's time to be a freaking grown-up you
know
sign your name on the same line with
everybody else on this budget
we
are deciding what we
are doing and it gets rid of all this
i'm your daddy i'm your mommy not your
husband or wife thing and he doesn't
have that that guy calling he's not got
any of that he's just trying to recover
from the emotions of all the mistakes
and like you said the guilt and the
shame but powerful part is like
financial peace university a byproduct
of that is you get on the same page
because you have shared language and
shared goals and a lot of couples have
that for the first time
exactly when they start doing a budget
we have had so many people going through
financial peace university that says
save their marriage and we're like dude
it was not a matter we didn't mean to
make a marriage it didn't mean to make a
marriage class but we forced them to be
in agreement we forced them to have both
have a vote to have the dignity of
speaking into their future
as a grown-up instead of being enabled
or caretaking or princesses
or princes or whatever it is it's
whatever the crap goes on in people's
dysfunctional marriages right
and so we're forcing them to back do
this together we're also forcing them to
come into agreement on what their fears
are and what their dreams are
and that will force you to have an
awesome marriage and those mistakes
it's a part of your story but it doesn't
define you your bankruptcy doesn't
define you but it's a part of your story
no and so i learned not to be quite as
stupid your identity isn't stupid you've
just done some stupid stuff i got a phd
in d-unb i graduated that's one less
than deloney you're almost there